l'office national israélien de tourisme
organisé hier une soirée d'information
au cinéma star à l'image
cette manifestation avait lieu avec le
concours des compagnies air france
el al et gym avec la collaboration du
syndicat d'initiative et des agences de
voyages de l'image des films sur israël
ont été présentés aux personnalités et
aux nombreux public
monsieur villemin notre ingénieur
régional récemment rentré d'israël
assistaient également à cette soirée
vers nous retrouvons maintenant notre
ingénieur régional monsieur ville un au
départ d'orly
entourée de tous nos confrères de la
presse écrite de la presse parlée et
télévisée qui l'avaient accompagné
et nous allons voir maintenant notre
caméra mal relais qu'outil qui vous avez
suivi également monsieur villemin et à
qui nous devons d'ailleurs ces images et
nous sommes maintenant arrivés une somme
à jérusalem
oui et preuve la chose qu'on prend
premier plan première chose qui est très
frappante pour le touriste déjà été en
israël
c'est cette frontière qui n'existe plus
qui a été abattu sauf en de rares
endroits par la guerre des six jours
on voyait actuellement les stigmates
j'ai eu quelques combats jérusalem
quelques combats assez durs les
israéliens s'efforce de faire
disparaître tous ces traces derrière
deux ans et voulait rien actuellement en
train de restaurer l'église de la
dormition de la vierge où se sont
déroulés ce dont nous de combat et je
pense que d'ici quelques temps
il paraîtra plus du tout parce qu'il a
de la célèbre mosquée d'omari la mosquée
d'omar qui est vraiment symbolise bien
la facilité on a maintenant de circuler
entre les deux quartiers les rues zalem
le quartier autrefois il serait agréable
quartiers arabes entre lesquels il y
avait une frontière ou maintenant on
peut circuler comme on veut un autre
haut lieu de l'histoire d'israël du
peuple d'israël c'est le mur de
lamentations on utilisait partie du
temps que mon salon bien sûr l'heure la
guitare en secret au lieu de d'israël
c'est vraiment le symbole de la terre
promise retrouvez est ici ou venus
passer un jour à tout le monde quel
point qu'un mur quelconque
on va déjà une certaine cool mais il
faut se dire que au lendemain de la
guerre des six jours et il y avait une
foule de plusieurs milliers de personnes
jerusalem évidemment c'est aussi des
lieux saints c'est aussi beaucoup de
monuments arabe
c'est un extraordinaire mélange de
civilisation et puis c'était au pied de
ces monuments tout le folklore et
orientale oui et qui lui ne pratiquement
ne bouge pas on retrouve les mêmes
ambiances con qu'on connaît dans près
tous les pays
c'est d'ailleurs des images à la
chronique aller chaboua côté des
building ou qui sont pas très loin des
billets à oui mais ça en israël
c'est vraiment disons normal tout change
extrêmement vite
nous sommes ici à saint jean d'âcre
c'est le plus grand souvenir qu'on est
des croisés pratiquement la dernière
citadelle qu'ils aient occupé et on va
pouvoir voir tu m'en vais tout ça on se
croirait vraiment du style français ont
du style que j'aimerais d'ailleurs
milité varty d'architecturé gothique et
voilà les armes on dit que les armoiries
des croisés qui luttent et combattre là
bas
l'un des soutiens de la forteresse est
au dessus de les voûtes que vous venez
de voir la mosquée la mosquée a été
construite au dessus de la citadelle des
croisés au hasard de vos de vos voyages
de vos promenades est ce que vous avez
eu des contacts avec l'homme de la rue
en israël
oui bien sûr nous avons eu quelques
contacts quoique ce ne soit pas toujours
très facile de parler à l'homme de la
rue en israël israël s'est formée de
populations venant des quatre coins du
monde et on ne sait jamais s'il faut
parler réussi faut parler anglais ou
américains ou en français quand même se
fait bien comprendre et bien sûr au
revoir ici nous sommes à césar et ça
fait bien ressortir l'effort énorme que
fait par les israéliens pour développer
le tourisme en effet ici l'esstin trait
au site
l'antiquité romaine ils ont entièrement
restauré le théâtre antique
aulas dans un autre domaine le miracle
d'israël une ville haifa une ville qui
n'existait pas il ya 20 ans
on a beaucoup parlé on a beaucoup écrit
sur israël et au travers de ce que vous
avez vu j'aimerais vous demander votre
opinion et bien l'opinion ne peut pas
être mieux symboliser que par le
kibboutz que nous voyons en ce moment
c'est l'extraordinaire dynamisme de
cette population
ils sont partis de terrain désertique et
dans ce terrain désertique
on voit maintenant des élevages
florissant des vaches qui produisent 25
litres de lait par jour ou 30 litres de
lait par jour
on voit une végétation magnifique et ils
sont partis initialement de rien et
voyez maintenant la façon d'y vivre
lilas large cantines restaurants velin
jardin d'enfants
quel est le trait dominant dans lequel
permet aux israéliens c'est le
certainement leur foi dans l'avenir leur
foi dans l'avenir qui est peut être
symbolise effectivement par ses vues de
jardins d'enfants que j'attache une
grande importance également par les
arbres ils ont planté 6 millions
d'arbres parce que d'une part l'arboux
importe la pluie et que l'arbre pour eux
symbolise la croissance la vie
à
nous sommes toujours à jérusalem
oui et voilà la jérusalem n'a cette fois
ci on a vu tout à l'heure jérusalem
vieille et voici contraste énorme entre
les deux pays
voilà ici le monument symbolise bien le
drame avec un effet israël sur ce
monument aux victimes nazis de la
dernière guerre mais je crois qu'il ne
faut pas trop s'attacher à ce passé pour
israël le passé sur un terreau promise
et je sais ils savent surtout se tourner
vers l'avenir
il n'y a pas débat
m